And everybody, this is Dr. Connors, and this video is on
Understanding Hashimoto's disease
And we're digging to the causes and concerns about triggers
So we talked a lot about triggers and the rest and the whole autoimmune course
We have to talk to you about it with Hashimoto's
Because that's the key concept in understanding
Any autoimmune disease, it's not a linear treatment protocol
It is three-dimensional, it's very complex, you have to look at
Multiple things that you know every single day
And that's what this whole course is trying to get you to
Look at autoimmune disease
In this video, Hashimoto's
Differently than just a straight, you know, hypothyroidism
We're trying to take this supplement and you're going to be cured
Or take this drug and you're going to be cured, it just doesn't work that way
So when we deal with autoimmune thyroid disease, whether it's graves or whether it's Hashimoto's
There's going to be lots of components here
The environment is going to affect it
There are certain genes that can be triggers to Hashimoto's that they've discovered
There's just other factors that are untouchable
The things just that we have to
That are triggers to every other autoimmune disease can be triggers to this disease as well
There are studies that show between studies that genetics definitely play a part in autoimmune disease
And the environmental triggers that we'll talk more about in just a second
Are huge players and huge triggers too, so you have to look at dietary triggers
We have to look at here's some dietary triggers
We've got to look at lifestyle triggers, we've got to look at every possible piece of this
I know this is
I'm kind of talking in circles here because if you don't look at these things
You're never going to get
You might literally have taken this course because you've been to 12 other doctors
And nobody's given you the right answers
The truth is, is nobody's going to be able to give you the right answers
We have to educate you in all the possible scenarios
So you have to do some testing and you have to do some identification of these triggers
Gluten is definitely going to be a trigger with Hashimoto's disease because
Of what we talked about that molecular mimicry issue
Salt can be a huge trigger with any autoimmune disease
There's study after study after study that show that some people, not everybody with autoimmune disease
But some people react to sodium intake, it can fire a reaction
Some people can have negative reactions to too much iodine
And certainly negative reactions to too little iodine
But that's something that you'd want to look at
You just, you have to know that there's not even a test for that
If you're taking iodine and you're still having these, these flares of your Hashimoto's
Maybe you need to back down on that
Electance is another food category that's commonly affects Hashimoto's disease
Lack of dietary diversity is huge
So we can't do like a Syrex 10 panel and show this person has, you know
100 foods that they have sensitivity to
And they're going to be eating down to 5 foods a day
You have to have diversity in your diet
So that's really important having some diversity
So you're not just eating the same things on a regular basis
That's how you can develop antibodies to those different foods
Certainly glyphosites are a huge issue
And glutamates that are in your food can be a huge issue
Inflammation in your diet just grades in general
Definitely k-seed because k-seed peptides can cross-react with glutam
Albumin can be an issue, dietary protein cross-reactivity
And I will actually have the list of all the gluten cross-reactants
That's what you would do that test the Syrex array 2
Which is the barrier test, 3x and 4
Those two arrays will give you the full gluten, gliad and picture
And all the cross-reactivity foods that are possible
That you could possibly be reacted to
So you might be on a gluten-free dairy-free diet
But you're eating something that you have a cross-reaction to
And you're getting the same trigger
So you do need to figure out those triggers
Lots of times you can do it with just a food elimination diet
Sometimes you want to get some testing done to really pinpoint things
Let me talk about lifestyle triggers
So it just gets more complicated
If I'm not sleeping well, if I'm not exercising too much
If you're smoking or you're out second-hand smoke
Alcohol can be definitely a trigger especially if you have microglial priming
Alcohol will trigger inflammation of the brain
Which will affect the hypothalamus of the pituitary link
And you'll have issues there
Any drug use
Even drug use that you need to be on for other reasons
Lack of rest
Unhealthy relationships
Which leads onto all sorts of stress issues
These are all potential triggers
In any autoimmune disease
And certainly in Hashimoto's
There's chemical triggers
Things that can disrupt your hormones
Things that can disrupt your gut biosis
The pesticides, air pollution
Fire retardants is huge
I had a patient once that called about their son
Who was having all sorts of issues
And it all stepped down to we tested him
And it was a fire retardant
They had just bought a new coach
And the son who had been sleeping on the coach
And his whole autoimmune system just absolutely flared up
Fire retardants in children's clothing
In all furniture
You know, the fabric of furniture and such
Benzines is a huge thing
Heavy metals, all sorts of chemicals, herbicides
And such as well
There are pathogen triggers
I haven't been exposed to H. Pylora
Hepatitis C exposure
That's a huge trigger for Hashimoto's
Another exposure to Epstein Bar
These things can go back and forth
I could have a latent Epstein Bar
And my thyroid is triggered by something else
And then that fires a trigger for my Epstein Bar
To go out of a latent stage
And become more active
That triggers my thyroid
It's just a mess
You have to be thinking three dimensionally
That's what I want you to understand about this
You have to be thinking
In the big picture
Anything can cause a trigger with Hashimoto's
With any autoimmune disease
And certainly Hashimoto's
And we're going to uncover these different
Webs in further videos here
But this is how complex it is
So if you want to a practitioner that's telling you that
Nope, you just need to take this magic supplement
Here's my protocol for autoimmune disease
Here's my protocol for Hashimoto's
I tell you, 90% of the people are going to be very disappointed
Because this is common reasons why practitioners fail
And let's talk about patients fail
With dealing with their Hashimoto's
Because they have unrealistic expectations
That they're just like one supplement to way
Of curing their problem
Or they have these linear protocols
And if I just fix my gut
And then I fix this
And I fix this
And I'm going to be
It's going to be no problem
We don't need to fix our gut
But there's so many pieces to this puzzle
That you need to be working on
Sometimes one at a time
Sometimes simultaneously
So not trying to cause depression through this
But I am trying to bring a reality
That this is the way you need to look at your life
It's not going to be just the simple, easy fix
Or not just a drug away from solving this problem
And I try to educate you so that you understand these concepts
That you're like, okay, now I can look at my symptoms
Differently see what could possibly flare that
Why I feel cruddy
Now it really helps you not become depressed
I think
So you don't think you're going crazy
And you don't think that you can never come out of this
You go through different clouds of confusion
What do you have an autoimmune disease
But I'm trying to get you to see that there
That you can get through it
And you just have to think a little bit differently
Keep studying
We're going to go through the webs
We've got a lot of more videos
Just in the Hashimoto section here
I know it's a lot
But I know you guys have been through a lot
And you're taking this course
Because you haven't found the answers
I don't claim to have them
I'm just claiming that my desires to work
Through these with you
To give you a better understanding
Know that I'm praying for you
Let's just continue on in our journey